in san francisco people waited in line
to get vaccinated for monkey pox a virus
that is spreading so rapidly the world
health organization has now declared it
a global health emergency
we have an outbreak that has spread
around the world rapidly
through new models of transmission
about which we understand too little and
which meets the criteria in the
international health regulations for all
of these reasons i have decided that the
global monkey box outbreak represents
a public health emergency of
international concern there have been
about 3 000 cases in the u.s so far and
many more in europe and dozens of other
countries including india russia and
brazil
matt ford battled the virus for more
than three weeks it was
excruciating at times you know
i had intense flu-like symptoms so fever
chills sore throat
cough sweating through my sheets at
night
and then you know the telltale skin
lesions which i had from the get-go but
more of them appeared throughout the
infection and towards the end i counted
more than 25 all over my body and they
just appeared everywhere
you know at worst on more sensitive skin
and more sensitive areas women and
children in the u.s have caught monkey
pox but the u.s centers for disease
control says 99 percent of the cases are
seen among gay and bisexual men the
disease is spread by close skin to skin
body contact monkey box vaccine and
testing kits are in short supply
frustrating health experts i think we
kind of stumbled out of the blocks in a
few ways one of which is testing i don't
think there was enough testing available
early enough and then the second thing
is with the vaccines we have vaccines
available they're approved we've have
them purchased they are in a national
stockpile and it's been getting them out
of the stockpile has been really
challenging and that's currently where
the bottleneck is right now the white
house says the government has
distributed three hundred thousand doses
of monkeypox vaccine and is trying to
speed up the shipment of about eight
hundred thousand more doses from denmark
where they are manufactured but that may
be too little too late i think i'm very
worried that the window for containing
this outbreak is closing quite quickly
and so without the vaccines i'm just
very nervous that we're not going to be
able to contain this as quickly as we'd
like matt ford said he's disappointed
that the public health response to the
outbreak seems sluggish
yeah i think the government response has
been very flawed and very delayed two
and a half years of dealing with the
covet pandemic public health systems in
the u.s and elsewhere are stretched to
their limits and ill-prepared to handle
new outbreaks of disease
rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles
jack chow's the former who assistant
director general and a global health
professor at carnegie mellon university
joins me now from washington d.c uh jack
by no means is the wh show unified on
this there are a lot of dissenting
voices within this whether it should
have been declared a global health
emergency it's been declared that is
this the who erring on the side of
caution or is this urging
governments to do more
well thank you for having me uh the who
convened two experts
uh meetings to deliberate on uh the
severity and the
uh urgency of responding to this crisis
and they developed a series of what i
would call a
epidemiological dashboard and
experts can
reasonably uh
look at the data over the past month and
think well there are some indicators
that
point to
rather
[Music]
that it's not as severe as one would
think however
the critical weakness of the data is
that it often lags reality that the
virus may be ahead of the data so
it's in my judgment that dr tedros is
airing on the side of taking pro-action
to mobilize governments and mobilize
civil society it's not only a medical
response it's a political response and
that is what is needed at all countries
at all community levels
in order to truncate
the epidemic
at the bud we have a lot of right now
pandemic fatigue people ordinary people
just fed up of the restrictions that
came with chronovirus travel
restrictions the mass etc etc and we
almost now are rolling into
this idea that monkey pox may be
spreading and once again people are just
like
well it turned out that kovid wasn't
that bad i mean that's what people think
maybe this isn't that bad either you are
fighting a public information campaign
here as well right
yes
we've gone through two years of covid
and there's a a pervasive psychological
resignation unfortunately
to the pandemic and to the voice of
science
and now we have monkey pox and monkey
pox can be very dangerous particularly
to pregnant women and their feed at
their developing fetus it can be very
dangerous to the immuno compromise
in certain circumstances it can cause
brain and spinal cord infection and even
blindness so while
there are patients such as the gentleman
who you interviewed earlier who have a
self-limited course
in many places of the world with fragile
health systems
death and disability as well as fear
stigma and discrimination
can can result so it really takes
a a concerted action at the global level
to to
hopefully eradicate what's going on
right now well the good news is is that
there is a vaccine the bad news is is
that in america the vaccine has been
stockpiled getting out of that stockpile
is proving to be difficult denmark which
manufactures the vaccine isn't hasn't
got the capacity to get it out
internationally uh not least quickly
anyway how much of that is a worry
what what is needed is a fulsome
response a blossoming of public health
capabilities that's commensurate with
the exponential growth of
the epidemic we've seen in the covet
campaigns that if ppe and the
ventilators are insufficient
then the virus runs rampant and
hospitals are swamped so it is
absolutely essential that the supply
chains open up
full bore and and the public health
officials and first-line implementers
have the equipment have the supplies
that they need so that uh patients can
avail themselves of the antivirals and
the vaccines as soon as cut as soon as
possible
but jack if that's the case then why not
force governments by
making this much more stronger than just
an advisory because an advisory means
that governments internationally can
ignore it
if it's that much of a problem if we
need to get this vaccine out why don't
we make it pandemic
well what we need is quite frankly a
pandemic response treaty and that has
been proposed it is uh going through the
slow diplomatic processes but monkey pox
compels ought to be compelling uh what i
would call a medical nato type of
response that countries are should knit
together and release stockpiles deploy
personnel to the front lines as soon as
possible the global health emergency
declaration who is a member state
organization it cannot command countries
it can advise and support countries but
it dr tedros declaration is an important
signal because it allows who a foothold
into the offices of presidents and prime
ministers to say fighting monkey pox
fighting covet fighting future pandemics
is a political responsibility as it is a
public health responsibility to their
constituents
jack chow live from washington d.c great
to have your thoughts thank you